This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.|||这是一个 I-Heart 播客。绝对真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难的学问》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·加姆斯。这个空间聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极不安全、却无比坦诚的对话，而你正在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人身披盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，就非得这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.|||在 AHA 广播应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难的学问》。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养精神坚韧度、健康体魄和复原力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.|||这就是 IHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方的《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个惯犯骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J.
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J.|||他会得到应有的下场。我们常说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝，在 IHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回顾过去》（Look Back at it）播客中。从 1979 年开始，那对我和来说是一个巨大的时刻。84 年对我也意义重大。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.|||我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊 80 年代。84 年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在 IHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。
And welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners. So great to have you here. So great to have you back. for another episode of the show. I'm so excited about what we're talking about today. And I think we're talking about something that is so relevant to our 20s. I'm surprised I haven't done it sooner. And that is whether the idea of the dream job is real or whether it's outdated. And kind of going into some of that psychology behind things like career anxiety and the cultural pressure to make our professional decisions.
And welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners. So great to have you here. So great to have you back. for another episode of the show. I'm so excited about what we're talking about today. And I think we're talking about something that is so relevant to our 20s. I'm surprised I haven't done it sooner. And that is whether the idea of the dream job is real or whether it's outdated. And kind of going into some of that psychology behind things like career anxiety and the cultural pressure to make our professional decisions.|||欢迎回到《二十岁心理学》（The psychology of your 20s），这是一个探讨我们在二十岁时经历的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听众，老听众。很高兴你们能来到这里。很高兴你们能回来收听节目的又一期。我对外今天我们要讨论的话题感到非常兴奋。而且我认为我们正在讨论的事情与我们的二十岁息息相关。我很惊讶自己没有早点做这个主题。那就是“梦想工作”的概念到底是真实的还是已经过时了。并深入探讨诸如职业焦虑等事物背后的部分心理学，以及做出职业决定的文化压力。
so early on in our lives while we feel stuck, and all that comes with trying to figure out exactly what we want to do with our lives. I think a huge component of our 20s is this task that we're given to figure out what we want to do with our lives. It's a fairly common question, right, that's lobbied at us from a fairly young age, not just our 20s, from relatives, from teachers in job interviews, almost every direction. And that's that question of what do you want to do? What is your dream job? It's a fairly large and terrifying question.
so early on in our lives while we feel stuck, and all that comes with trying to figure out exactly what we want to do with our lives. I think a huge component of our 20s is this task that we're given to figure out what we want to do with our lives. It's a fairly common question, right, that's lobbied at us from a fairly young age, not just our 20s, from relatives, from teachers in job interviews, almost every direction. And that's that question of what do you want to do? What is your dream job? It's a fairly large and terrifying question.|||在我们的生活中如此早期、当我们感到迷茫的时候，以及伴随着试图弄清楚我们究竟想用自己的人生做什么而产生的一切。我认为我们二十岁的一个重要组成部分，就是被赋予了去弄清楚我们想用一生做什么的任务。这是一个相当常见的问题，对吧？我们在很小的时候就被问到这个问题，不仅仅是在二十岁的时候，亲戚会问，求职面试中的老师会问，几乎来自四面八方。这就是那个问题：你想做什么？你的梦想工作是什么？这是一个相当宏大且让人恐慌的问题。
And in many ways, I think it can leave us feeling fairly stuck for a number of reasons. You know, the world is so large. There are so many opportunities and possibilities. But there are also so many barriers and limitations, so many factors that are going to contribute to what career we want to have and also what is available to us. And sometimes I think we get to our dream position and we realize that it is not all that we want or that since setting that goal, our desires have changed. So what I want to discuss today is whether the dream job, our dream job, really exists,
And in many ways, I think it can leave us feeling fairly stuck for a number of reasons. You know, the world is so large. There are so many opportunities and possibilities. But there are also so many barriers and limitations, so many factors that are going to contribute to what career we want to have and also what is available to us. And sometimes I think we get to our dream position and we realize that it is not all that we want or that since setting that goal, our desires have changed. So what I want to discuss today is whether the dream job, our dream job, really exists,|||在许多方面，我认为由于种种原因，它会让我们感到相当迷茫。你知道，世界是如此之大。有那么多的机会和可能性。但也有那么多的障碍和限制，有太多的因素会决定我们想要从事什么职业以及我们能够获得什么。有时我认为，当我们达到了我们梦寐以求的职位时，我们却意识到这并非我们想要的全部，或者自从设定那个目标以来，我们的欲望已经改变了。所以我今天要讨论的是，梦想工作——我们的梦想工作——是否真的存在，
whether there is only one dream job. And just dissect some of that pressure we often face to have it figured. out so early on in our lives. If you have been feeling perhaps a lot of anxiety around choosing your career pathway or your degree or trying to figure out what is actually going to make you happy career-wise, I promise that you're not alone. I've definitely felt this way even recently in my current job and asking myself those questions of is this really what I want? Does this make me happy and simultaneous to that. I've been having this discussion quite a lot with my friends the past few months about their perspectives and their struggles as fellow 20-something people. And throughout
whether there is only one dream job. And just dissect some of that pressure we often face to have it figured. out so early on in our lives. If you have been feeling perhaps a lot of anxiety around choosing your career pathway or your degree or trying to figure out what is actually going to make you happy career-wise, I promise that you're not alone. I've definitely felt this way even recently in my current job and asking myself those questions of is this really what I want? Does this make me happy and simultaneous to that. I've been having this discussion quite a lot with my friends the past few months about their perspectives and their struggles as fellow 20-something people. And throughout|||是否真的只有一个梦想工作。并剖析我们经常面临的那种必须在生命如此早期就把它想明白的压力。如果你在选择职业道路、学位，或者试图弄清楚到底什么才能让你的职业生涯感到快乐时，可能感受到了很大的焦虑，我向你保证，你并不孤单。甚至在我最近的工作中，我也确实有过这种感觉，我会问自己这些问题：这真的是我想要的吗？这能让我快乐吗？与此同时，在过去的几个月里，我和朋友们经常讨论他们作为同龄的二十几岁年轻人所持的观点和挣扎。在整个
all of that noise and those conversations, I couldn't help but think there has to be some research, some psychological explanation behind this concept. And there definitely was. So perhaps you're listening to this with a fairly clear idea of what you want to do. a fairly mapped out path to your destination. I think jobs like, you know, being a surgeon or a lawyer, they're fairly traditional career pathways, and they have clear entry points, clear degree and experience requirements. And they might take some time, but the idea is that if you do everything right,
all of that noise and those conversations, I couldn't help but think there has to be some research, some psychological explanation behind this concept. And there definitely was. So perhaps you're listening to this with a fairly clear idea of what you want to do. a fairly mapped out path to your destination. I think jobs like, you know, being a surgeon or a lawyer, they're fairly traditional career pathways, and they have clear entry points, clear degree and experience requirements. And they might take some time, but the idea is that if you do everything right,|||喧嚣和对话中，我不禁想，在这个概念背后一定有一些研究、一些心理学解释。确实如此。所以也许你带着对你想做的事情相当清晰的想法来听这期节目。有一条通往你目的地的相当明确的规划路径。我认为诸如外科医生或律师之类的工作，它们是相当传统的职业道路，并且有明确的切入点、明确的学位和经验要求。这可能需要一些时间，但其理念是，如果你把每件事都做对了，
if you follow the correct path, you know, in five years time, you'll be where you want to be. And that sounds straightforward, right? but so often we're forced to decide fairly young, even at the beginning of high school, what we want to do when we're, you know, 16, 17, 18 years old. And those dreams that we set for ourselves then, they are going to change. And what happens when you arrive at that destination or you retrieve that dream job, and you find it really unfulfilling?
if you follow the correct path, you know, in five years time, you'll be where you want to be. And that sounds straightforward, right? but so often we're forced to decide fairly young, even at the beginning of high school, what we want to do when we're, you know, 16, 17, 18 years old. And those dreams that we set for ourselves then, they are going to change. And what happens when you arrive at that destination or you retrieve that dream job, and you find it really unfulfilling?|||如果你遵循正确的道路，你知道，五年后，你就会到达你想去的地方。这听起来很简单，对吧？但我们常常被迫在很年轻的时候就做决定，甚至在高中刚开始时，也就是在我们 16、17、18 岁的时候，就决定我们想做什么。而我们当时为自己设定的那些梦想，是会改变的。当你到达那个目的地或找到那个梦想工作，却发现它其实并不能带来满足感时，会发生什么？
That's a massive dilemma. And my friend Aaron, a good friend of the show, she also said something to me the other day that was actually really enlightening and kind of struck me as really poignant. And that's what if you just don't even have a dream job? What if you can't imagine your ideal career or that just doesn't appeal to you? You know, a job is just something that you have to pay your bills and allow you to live out your passions elsewhere away from the workplace. Like why is that not an acceptable answer to that question of what do you want to do? I think it should be fine to say, you know, my career and my professional life, it isn't actually the center of my universe. A job, it's just a job to me. It doesn't need to mean more than that. And there's so much just, you know, to discuss around
That's a massive dilemma. And my friend Aaron, a good friend of the show, she also said something to me the other day that was actually really enlightening and kind of struck me as really poignant. And that's what if you just don't even have a dream job? What if you can't imagine your ideal career or that just doesn't appeal to you? You know, a job is just something that you have to pay your bills and allow you to live out your passions elsewhere away from the workplace. Like why is that not an acceptable answer to that question of what do you want to do? I think it should be fine to say, you know, my career and my professional life, it isn't actually the center of my universe. A job, it's just a job to me. It doesn't need to mean more than that. And there's so much just, you know, to discuss around|||这是一个巨大的困境。我的朋友亚伦（Aaron），这位节目的好朋友，前几天也对我说了一些话，实际上非常具有启发性，让我觉得直击心扉。那就是，如果你根本没有梦想 job 呢？如果你无法想象你的理想职业，或者这根本吸引不了你呢？你知道，工作只是一件让你用来支付账单、并让你在远离工作场所的其他地方去实现你的热情的事情。为什么对于“你想做什么”这个问题，这不是一个可以接受的答案呢？我认为完全可以这样说：你知道，我的事业和我的职业生活，其实并不是我宇宙的中心。工作对我来说只是一份工作。它不需要有更深层的意义。有太多，你知道的，需要围绕……进行讨论的话题
this concept of the dream job and as we'll uncover a lot more research and literature than I thought because regardless of whether you have a dream job, whether you know what you want to do with your life or not, the truth is that work and our careers are a fundamental. mental part of our lives, not just our 20s, how we make money, it's going to consume more hours of our lives than any other activity besides, you know, maybe sleeping. So understanding the dynamic around the decisions we make when it comes to our careers is super important. There's so much to cover. I know I say that every time, but there is so much fascinating research and psychology around this topic. There's literally an entire field of
this concept of the dream job and as we'll uncover a lot more research and literature than I thought because regardless of whether you have a dream job, whether you know what you want to do with your life or not, the truth is that work and our careers are a fundamental. mental part of our lives, not just our 20s, how we make money, it's going to consume more hours of our lives than any other activity besides, you6 know, maybe sleeping. So understanding the dynamic around the decisions we make when it comes to our careers is super important. There's so much to cover. I know I say that every time, but there is so much fascinating research and psychology around this topic. There's literally an entire field of|||梦想工作的这个概念，正如我们将要揭示的，比我想象的要多得多的研究和文献，因为无论你是否有梦想工作，无论你知道自己想用生命做什么还是不知道，事实是，工作和我们的职业生涯是生活中的一个根本组成部分，不仅仅是二十岁，我们赚钱的方式，它将消耗我们生命中比除了睡觉之外的任何其他活动都多的时间。因此，理解我们在做职业决定时的动态关系超级重要。有太多内容要涵盖了。我知道我每次都这么说，但围绕这个话题有太多迷人的研究和心理学。简直有一个完整的……领域
psychology called organizational psychology that is dedicated to our relationship with work and our jobs so buckle in because today we're going to break down the psychology of the dream job is it fact is it fiction all of those good things i think to begin we all have some concept or idea of what i mean when i talk about the dream job and all the fantasy and the dreams and the hopes that we attach to it. When we think about the dream job, we think about the thing that we feel we were perhaps born to do. The thing that lights our soul, the job we think will complete us and in some ways make us really, really happy.
psychology called organizational psychology that is dedicated to our relationship with work and our jobs so buckle in because today we're going to break down the psychology of the dream job is it fact is it fiction all of those good things i think to begin we all have some concept or idea of what i mean when i talk about the dream job and all the fantasy and the dreams and the hopes that we attach to it. When we think about the dream job, we think about the thing that we feel we were perhaps born to do. The thing that lights our soul, the job we think will complete us and in some ways make us really, really happy.|||心理学被称为组织心理学，它专门研究我们与工作和职业的关系，所以系好安全带，因为今天我们要剖析梦想工作的心理学：它是事实还是虚构，所有这些美好的东西。我想首先，当我们谈论梦想工作以及我们附加在其上的所有幻想、梦想和希望时，我们大家都有一些概念或想法。当我们想到梦想工作时，我们会想到我们觉得自己可能是天生要做的那件事。点燃我们灵魂的事情，我们认为能让人生完整、并在某种程度上让我们真正非常快乐的工作。
And there is no denying that there are some people who have their dream job, who have discovered their dream job. Maybe they have stumbled upon it. you know, the thing that they feel on this planet to do and they can't imagine doing anything else. I also think, you know, there are people in the broader pop culture sphere who we can't imagine doing anything else, you know, like Taylor Swift or Oprah. Like, can you imagine them being a barista or a gardener? No, there's just some people, I think, who have a calling and they're able to follow it through, but I'm sure even these people at time have doubts. But if that is you and you've hacked the system and you have achieved your dream job. I think that's incredible and I'm so proud of you and I'm sure you're
And there is no denying that there are some people who have their dream job, who have discovered their dream job. Maybe they have stumbled upon it. you know, the thing that they feel on this planet to do and they can't imagine doing anything else. I also think, you know, there are people in the broader pop culture sphere who we can't imagine doing anything else, you know, like Taylor Swift or Oprah. Like, can you imagine them being a barista or a gardener? No, there's just some people, I think, who have a calling and they're able to follow it through, but I'm sure even these people at time have doubts. But if that is you and you've hacked the system and you have achieved your dream job. I think that's incredible and I'm so proud of you and I'm sure you're|||不可否认，确实有一些人拥有他们的梦想工作，已经发现了他们的梦想工作。也许他们是偶然发现的。你知道，他们觉得来到这个星球就是为了做这件事，而且他们无法想象做其他任何事情。我也认为，你知道，在更广泛的流行文化领域里，有些人我们无法想象他们去做别的，你知道，比如泰勒·斯威夫特（Taylor Swift）或奥普拉（Oprah）。比如，你能想象他们成为咖啡师或园丁吗？不，我认为确实有些人有一种天职，并且他们能够将其贯彻到底，但我确信即使是这些人有时也会有疑问。但如果那就是你，并且你破解了系统、实现了你的梦想工作。我认为这太不可思议了，我为你感到骄傲，而且我确信你……
doing amazing, but you're definitely one of the lucky ones and maybe you were someone who always thought they had a clear idea and you always knew what your dream job was and now you're listening to this podcast because you realize that maybe you're a mistake and it's not as easy as that and you're feeling a little bit stuck. One question I had when I was thinking about this concept and writing this episode is where did this idea even come from? Like this idea of a dream job seems so bizarre and I had a few ideas and did some further digging just to kind of understand where this idea came from. And it was pretty hard to find the etymology of the term, but it appears that it became popular in the 20th century, especially as education levels begin to rise and
doing amazing, but you're definitely one of the lucky ones and maybe you were someone who always thought they had a clear idea and you always knew what your dream job was and now you're listening to this podcast because you realize that maybe you're a mistake and it's not as easy as that and you're feeling a little bit stuck. One question I had when I was thinking about this concept and writing this episode is where did this idea even come from? Like this idea of a dream job seems so bizarre and I had a few ideas and did some further digging just to kind of understand where this idea came from. And it was pretty hard to find the etymology of the term, but it appears that it became popular in the 20th century, especially as education levels begin to rise and|||做得很好，但你绝对是幸运儿之一。也许你曾认为自己一直有个清晰的想法，并且一直都知道你的梦想工作是什么，而现在你收听这个播客是因为你意识到也许你搞错了，事情并没有那么简单，你感到有点迷茫。当我思考这个概念并写这一集时，我有一个问题：这个想法究竟是从哪里来的？“梦想工作”这个想法看起来如此离奇，我有了一些想法，并做了一些深入挖掘，只是为了解这个想法究竟源自何处。要找到这个词的词源相当困难，但它似乎在 20 世纪开始流行起来，特别是在教育水平开始提高、
incomes expanded, people were no longer resigned to work. the jobs that their fathers and their mothers had worked. And after World War II, I think many Western countries saw what was a massive rise in wealth. And with that, an opportunity to be able to pick a job that you enjoyed rather than one that, you know, just prevented you from starving. And the idea of the dream job was born. That belief, I think, has slowly expanded. And the idea has become a lot more common.
incomes expanded, people were no longer resigned to work. the jobs that their fathers and their mothers had worked. And after World War II, I think many Western countries saw what was a massive rise in wealth. And with that, an opportunity to be able to pick a job that you enjoyed rather than one that, you know, just prevented you from starving. And the idea of the dream job was born. That belief, I think, has slowly expanded. And the idea has become a lot more common.|||收入增加的时候，人们不再甘于去做他们父亲和母亲做过的工作。二战后，我认为许多西方国家迎来了财富的大幅增长。随之而来的是一个能够选择自己喜欢的工作的机会，而不是那种仅仅能让你免于挨饿的工作。梦想工作的概念就这样诞生了。我认为，这种信念在慢慢扩大。这个想法也变得越来越普遍。
especially as we've seen, you know, entirely new industries emerge in recent decades with the invention of the internet and the expansions in technology. Basically, there was a shift from work being a chore, a necessity, to something that we can hopefully enjoy and strive towards. I think we all know the term exists, and maybe for you it means nothing. you're not someone who dreams of labor, as they say. But undoubtedly, for many of us, there is still a lingering feeling or a need to absolutely adore what we do to be happy. So where exactly does that pressure come from?
especially as we've seen, you know, entirely new industries emerge in recent decades with the invention of the internet and the expansions in technology. Basically, there was a shift from work being a chore, a necessity, to something that we can hopefully enjoy and strive towards. I think we all know the term exists, and maybe for you it means nothing. you're not someone who dreams of labor, as they say. But undoubtedly, for many of us, there is still a lingering feeling or a need to absolutely adore what we do to be happy. So where exactly does that pressure come from?|||特别是在过去的几十年里，随着互联网的发明和技术的扩展，我们看到了全新的行业涌现。基本上，工作从一种杂务、一种必需品，转变为一种我们希望能够享受并为之奋斗的事物。我想我们都知道这个词的存在，也许对你来说它毫无意义。正如他们所说，你不是一个梦想劳动的人。但毫无疑问，对我们中的许多人来说，仍然有一种挥之不去的感觉，或者有一种必须绝对热爱我们所做的事情才能快乐的需求。那么，这种压力究竟从何而来？
Where does the pressure to discover our dream job come from? I think personally, it starts really, really young. Think back to when we were children. already we did have some concept that what we would eventually do for a living was something to fantasize about and create goals towards. We dreamed of being ballerinas or doctors or teachers, marine biologists, fashion designers, you name it. Even at such a young age, we were already conditioned from modeling our parents' behavior and the people around us to see work, to see, our jobs as something that was hierarchical whereby there were some jobs that were filled with joy and passion and which will make us happy and there were other jobs that just needed to be done and
Where does the pressure to discover our dream job come from? I think personally, it starts really, really young. Think back to when we were children. already we did have some concept that what we would eventually do for a living was something to fantasize about and create goals towards. We dreamed of being ballerinas or doctors or teachers, marine biologists, fashion designers, you name it. Even at such a young age, we were already conditioned from modeling our parents' behavior and the people around us to see work, to see, our jobs as something that was hierarchical whereby there were some jobs that were filled with joy and passion and which will make us happy and there were other jobs that just needed to be done and|||发现我们梦想工作的压力从何而来？我个人认为，它在非常、非常年轻的时候就开始了。回想一下我们还是孩子的时候。那时我们其实就已经有了一些概念，即我们最终凭什么谋生是一件可以去幻想并为之制定目标的事情。我们梦想成为芭蕾舞演员、医生、教师、海洋生物学家、时装设计师，等等。甚至在那么小的年纪，我们就已经通过模仿父母的行为和周围人的行为而受到潜移默化的影响，把工作、把我们的工作看作是有等级之分的：有些工作充满了快乐和激情，能让我们快乐；而另一些工作则只是需要完成的、
we may have even seen our parents you know incredibly dissatisfied with work and those early childhood experiences the experiences of our parents they leave an impression on us and it kind of determines where we see ourselves in the future, in the future. And it kind of leaves this impression of, you know, I never want to be like that. I never want to work a job that I hate. You know, I feel like a lot more children probably want to be an author or the Prime Minister than a debt collector, even though I think all jobs have an important place
we may have even seen our parents you know incredibly dissatisfied with work and those early childhood experiences the experiences of our parents they leave an impression on us and it kind of determines where we see ourselves in the future, in the future. And it kind of leaves this impression of, you know, I never want to be like that. I never want to work a job that I hate. You know, I feel like a lot more children probably want to be an author or the Prime Minister than a debt collector, even though I think all jobs have an important place|||我们甚至可能看到我们的父母对工作感到无比的不满，而那些早期童年的经历、我们父母的经历，在我们的身上留下了印记，并且它在某种程度上决定了我们在未来如何看待自己。它留下了这样一种印象：你知道，我绝不想成为那样的人。我绝不想做一份我讨厌的工作。你知道，我觉得想成为作家或首相的孩子可能比想成为收债员的孩子多得多，尽管我认为所有工作在社会中都有其重要的一席之地。
in society. And part of that is because there are jobs that are idealized and made to seem amazing and made to seem like a dream. and others that don't really get a mention. They're just not glamorous or they're not visible. And so from that early age, we're indoctrinated with this idea of a dream job. And there's other ways that this concept comes up and leaves an impression on us unconsciously or implicitly. There's a quote that I'm sure we've all heard in some form that if you love what you do,
in society. And part of that is because there are jobs that are idealized and made to seem amazing and made to seem like a dream. and others that don't really get a mention. They're just not glamorous or they're not visible. And so from that early age, we're indoctrinated with this idea of a dream job. And there's other ways that this concept comes up and leaves an impression on us unconsciously or implicitly. There's a quote that I'm sure we've all heard in some form that if you love what you do,|||一部分原因在于，有些工作被理想化了，被描绘得无比神奇，就像一个梦想。而另一些工作则几乎无人提及。它们不够光鲜亮丽，或者不够显眼。因此，从那么小的时候起，我们就潜移默化地接受了梦想工作的概念。还有其他一些方式让这个概念出现，并在无意识或潜移默化中给我们留下深刻印象。有一句我们肯定都在某种程度上听过的名言：如果你热爱你所做的事，
you'll never work a day in your life. and we see similar messages in so many areas of our lives and it might seem innocent enough and in some ways it definitely makes sense right like when we love our work when we enjoy doing it we will want to do it the same way we want to do a hobby or anything else that we love and enjoy but i think there's something more insidious about this idea that can create a lot of doubt and pressure on those of us who don't have it figured out yet which I think is probably well, you know, the majority of the people who are listening. And do what you love is such privileged advice, right?
you'll never work a day in your life. and we see similar messages in so many areas of our lives and it might seem innocent enough and in some ways it definitely makes sense right like when we love our work when we enjoy doing it we will want to do it the same way we want to do a hobby or anything else that we love and enjoy but i think there's something more insidious about this idea that can create a lot of doubt and pressure on those of us who don't have it figured out yet which I think is probably well, you know, the majority of the people who are listening. And do what you love is such privileged advice, right?|||你这一辈子都不会觉得在工作。我们在生活的许多领域都能看到类似的讯息，这看起来可能足够天真无邪，在某些方面它也确实讲得通，对吧？比如当我们热爱我们的工作、当我们享受其中时，我们会想要去做它，就像我们想要去培养一个爱好或任何其他我们热爱和享受的事情一样。但我认为这个想法中隐藏着更阴险的东西，它会给那些尚未想清楚的人——我认为这可能就是，你知道的，正在收听的大多数人——带来很多的怀疑和压力。而且“做你热爱的事”这种建议带有极大的特权，对吧？
And it really ignores the fact that most of the world's population, most of the people walking up and down the street, they don't really have the luxury of choosing to do something they really love. You know, a job is the way that they, you know, receive financial support. It's the way that they eat and they house themselves. And it's not necessarily for emotional fulfillment. I think also it can be kind of awful and it can create a lot of shame when you don't love your career. And when people are telling you that you should because it promotes this idea once again from an early age,
And it really ignores the fact that most of the world's population, most of the people walking up and down the street, they don't really have the luxury of choosing to do something they really love. You know, a job is the way that they, you know, receive financial support. It's the way that they eat and they house themselves. And it's not necessarily for emotional fulfillment. I think also it can be kind of awful and it can create a lot of shame when you don't love your career. And when people are telling you that you should because it promotes this idea once again from an early age,|||它真正忽视了这样一个事实：世界上绝大多数人口，那些在大街上走来走去的人们，并没有真正奢侈地去选择做他们真正热爱的事情。你知道，工作是他们获得经济支持的方式。这是他们赖以生存和安身立命的方式。它不一定是为了情感上的满足。我认为这也是一件相当糟糕的事情，当你并不热爱你的职业时，它会产生很多羞耻感。当人们告诉你你应该去热爱时，因为它再次从小就宣扬了这样一种观念：
that what matters most in your life is what you do professionally. That our jobs, they are the centre of our lives, our primary source of happiness. And if we don't enjoy what we do, if we don't have a clue about what we want to do, you know, we're not going to be happy. And, you know, there's sometimes there's things that we love doing and we just can't make a living. You know, work can just be work. And you're allowed to be satisfied with that. And when we're continually hearing that message, particularly if you are working a job that you don't like or you realize that your dream job is just kind of hyped up the panic. That career anxiety that we talk about quite frequently, that's what we're working. That's what we're
that what matters most in your life is what you do professionally. That our jobs, they are the centre of our lives, our primary source of happiness. And if we don't enjoy what we do, if we don't have a clue about what we want to do, you know, we're not going to be happy. And, you know, there's sometimes there's things that we love doing and we just can't make a living. You know, work can just be work. And you're allowed to be satisfied with that. And when we're continually hearing that message, particularly if you are working a job that you don't like or you realize that your dream job is just kind of hyped up the panic. That career anxiety that we talk about quite frequently, that's what we're working. That's what we're|||你生命中最重要的是你在职业上做什么。我们的工作是我们生活的中心，是我们幸福的主要来源。如果我们不享受我们所做的事，如果我们对想做什么一无所知，你知道，我们就不会快乐。而且，你知道，有时有些事情是我们喜欢做的，但我们就是无法以此谋生。你知道，工作可以只是工作。你完全可以对此感到满足。当我们不断听到这种信息时，特别是如果你正在做一份你不喜欢的工作，或者你意识到你的梦想工作只是一种被炒作起来的虚幻时，恐慌感就产生了。我们经常谈论的这种职业焦虑，就是这样产生的。这就是我们……
when it starts to emerge. In addition, and on top of that messaging, like that quote that I mentioned, we're also getting a lot of these expectations from our families and our teachers and our friends and the media that we need to know what we want to do. We need to have a dream job in mind. And a lot of that pressure has been passed down from generation to generation as our careers have become much larger and a greater contribution to our identity. You know, we spend more time in the workplace. retire later, we're seeing inflation rise to the extent that we do have to work longer hours and for more years. And, you know, we're in a recession right now. The cost of living is so high and we need a way to afford to live and to pay our bills. And being told that there's a way to work
when it starts to emerge. In addition, and on top of that messaging, like that quote that I mentioned, we're also getting a lot of these expectations from our families and our teachers and our friends and the media that we need to know what we want to do. We need to have a dream job in mind. And a lot of that pressure has been passed down from generation to generation as our careers have become much larger and a greater contribution to our identity. You know, we spend more time in the workplace. retire later, we're seeing inflation rise to the extent that we do have to work longer hours and for more years. And, you0 know, we're in a recession right now. The cost of living is so high and we need a way to afford to live and to pay our bills. And being told that there's a way to work|||开始浮现的时候。此外，除了那种信息之外，就像我提到的那句名言一样，我们还从家庭、老师、朋友和媒体那里收到了很多这样的期望：我们需要知道自己想做什么。我们需要心怀一个梦想工作。随着我们的职业生涯变得越来越庞大、对我们的身份认同做出了更大的贡献，这种压力在很大程度上代代相传。你知道，我们在职场花的时间更多了。退休得更晚了，我们看到通货膨胀上升到我们确实不得不工作更长时间、更多年头的程度。而且，你知道，我们现在正处于经济衰退中。生活成本如此之高，我们需要一种方法来负担生活和支付账单。当被告知有一种工作方式……
and still enjoy life through this myth of the dream job is a pretty excellent way to distract us from the cognitive dissonance associated with maybe that deeper acknowledgement that work doesn't really have to be the center of our days and of our lives. And that it's kind of unnatural. We probably want to be doing other things rather than being cooped up in an office. And like I said before, most of us will end up working eight or more hours a day for most of our working and adult lives. So it does make sense that if we're told that we can enjoy what we do and even bigger than that, that our careers determine so much of our identity, it's going to make us feel better about how much time we're devoting to these tasks. And that's another point. Our career is a
and still enjoy life through this myth of the dream job is a pretty excellent way to distract us from the cognitive dissonance associated with maybe that deeper acknowledgement that work doesn't really have to be the center of our days and of our lives. And that it's kind of unnatural. We probably want to be doing other things rather than being cooped up in an office. And like I said before, most of us will end up working eight or more hours a day for most of our working and adult lives. So it does make sense that if we're told that we can enjoy what we do and even bigger than that, that our careers determine so much of our identity, it's going to make us feel better about how much time we're devoting to these tasks. And that's another point. Our career is a|||并且还能通过“梦想工作”这个神话来享受生活时，这是一个极好的方法，可以将我们的注意力从认知失调中转移开，这种认知失调或许与那种更深层的认知有关，即工作其实并不一定非要成为我们每一天和生活的中心。而且这其实有点不自然。我们可能更想做别的事情，而不是被关在办公室里。就像我之前说的，我们大多数人在大部分的工作和成年生活中，最终都会每天工作八小时或更长时间。所以这确实讲得通：如果我们被告知我们可以享受我们所做的事，甚至更宏大的是，我们的职业决定了我们身份的很大一部分，这会让我们对投入这些任务的时间感到好受一些。这就是另一点。我们的职业是……
huge determinant of our identity. So we want to choose the right one, right? Think about the most recent time you met someone new. Maybe it was at a party or through a mutual friend or you matched on a dating app. I promise you, one of the first questions I'm sure they asked is what do you do for a living or where do you work? It's so common and it indicates how much our identity and people's perception of us is determined by what we do for a living. You know, I was asked this question at a party the other day and it was so exhausting. There were so many new people there by the end of the night. I honestly just started making stuff up. I was so frustrated. I think I told someone I was a reptile vet. Don't even know if that's a job. And, you know, another person,
huge determinant of our identity. So we want to choose the right one, right? Think about the most recent time you met someone new. Maybe it was at a party or through a mutual friend or you matched on a dating app. I promise you, one of the first questions I'm sure they asked is what do you do for a living or where do you work? It's so common and it indicates how much our identity and people's perception of us is determined by what we do for a living. You know, I was asked this question at a party the other day and it was so exhausting. There were so many new people there by the end of the night. I honestly just started making stuff up. I was so frustrated. I think I told someone I was a reptile vet. Don't even know if that's a job. And, you know, another person,|||我们身份的一个巨大决定因素。所以我们想要选择对的那一个，对吧？想想你最近一次遇到新人的情景。也许是在派对上，通过共同的朋友，或者在约会软件上匹配到。我向他们保证，我敢肯定他们问的第一个问题之一就是你是做什么谋生的或者你在哪里工作？这太常见了，它表明了我们的身份以及人们对我们的看法在很大程度上是由我们谋生的手段决定的。你知道，前几天我在一个派对上被问到这个问题，太累人了。那天晚上有太多新面孔了，到最后我简直开始胡编乱造了。我太沮丧了。我想我曾告诉某人我是一名爬行动物兽医。甚至不知道那算不算一份工作。而且，你知道，另一个人……
that I was an electrician, almost as like a social experiment to see their reaction and how they changed their perception of me because we might try and deny it, but our jobs, our careers are a pretty major pillar of our identity, particularly the outward appearance of our identity as, you know, prominent, I think, is, you know, our friends and our families, our likes, our dislikes, our appearance, our personality. And this is only exacerbated when we begin to link our self-esteem. to our work performance or to our job selection. There's been some really interesting studies on the outcome of this
that I was an electrician, almost as like a social experiment to see their reaction and how they changed their perception of me because we might try and deny it, but our jobs, our careers are a pretty major pillar of our identity, particularly the outward appearance of our identity as, you know, prominent, I think, is, you know, our friends and our families, our likes, our dislikes, our appearance, our personality. And this is only exacerbated when we begin to link our self-esteem. to our work performance or to our job selection. There's been some really interesting studies on the outcome of this|||说我是一名电工，几乎就像是一个社会实验，想看看他们的反应以及他们如何改变对我的看法，因为我们可能会试图否认，但我们的工作、我们的职业是我们身份的一个相当主要的支柱，特别是我们身份的外在表现，你知道，我认为很显著的是，你知道，我们的朋友和家人、我们的喜好、我们的厌恶、我们的外表、我们的个性。当我们开始将我们的自尊与我们的工作表现或工作选择联系起来时，这种情况只会更加恶化。有一些非常有趣的研究探讨了这种结果……
interlinkage between our professional lives and our identities. And a longitudinal study in the US, it's actually still ongoing, it's still being conducted, but so far they've shown some preliminary insights that the work we do does shape our personality and the things like our sense of control over our environment, our confidence, how proactive we are. And our work also has an important economic and social implications such that the outcomes of our work performance actually have consequences for our sense of security and our livelihood. So research has found that when we are happy at work, when we are feeling fulfilled,
interlinkage between our professional lives and our identities. And a longitudinal study in the US, it's actually still ongoing, it's still being conducted, but so far they've shown some preliminary insights that the work we do does shape our personality and the things like our sense of control over our environment, our confidence, how proactive we are. And our work also has an important economic and social implications such that the outcomes of our work performance actually have consequences for our sense of security and our livelihood. So research has found that when we are happy at work, when we are feeling fulfilled,|||专业生活与我们的身份认同之间的相互联系。美国的一项纵向研究，实际上仍在进行中，仍在开展，但到目前为止，它们已经显示出一些初步的见解，即我们所做的工作确实塑造了我们的性格，以及诸如我们对环境的控制感、我们的自信、我们的积极性等事物。我们的工作也具有重要的经济和社会意义，以至于我们工作表现的结果实际上会对我们的安全感和生计产生影响。因此研究发现，当我们对工作感到快乐、当我们感到充实时，
this can actually lead us to feel more secure and then more extroverted, whereas when we feel that we are underperforming or we're unsatisfied or are unfulfilled, we experience more neuroticism, more anxiety and even depression. And with all of that in mind, I want to stress, you know, enjoying what you do does come with lots of benefits. Like I just said, you know, personality, identity, self-esteem, it's linked to what we do in our professional lives. It's linked to our careers. And I don't think that that debate, you know, that you shouldn't be allowed to enjoy your career is what I'm talking about. I think more than that, it's that you can be satisfied without knowing what you want to do.
this can actually lead us to feel more secure and then more extroverted, whereas when we feel that we are underperforming or we're unsatisfied or are unfulfilled, we experience more neuroticism, more anxiety and even depression. And with all of that in mind, I want to stress, you know, enjoying what you do does come with lots of benefits. Like I just said, you know, personality, identity, self-esteem, it's linked to what we do in our professional lives. It's linked to our careers. And I don't think that that debate, you know, that you shouldn't be allowed to enjoy your career is what I'm talking about. I think more than that, it's that you can be satisfied without knowing what you want to do.|||这实际上可以让我们感到更有安全感，从而更加外向；而当我们觉得自己表现不佳、不满意或没有成就感时，我们会经历更多的神经质、更多的焦虑甚至抑郁。带着所有这些想法，我想强调的是，你知道，享受你所做的事确实会带来很多好处。就像我刚才说的，你知道，性格、身份、自尊，它们都与我们在职业生活中所做的事情息息相关。它们与我们的职业生涯息息相关。我不认为那场争论——你知道，即你不应该被允许享受你的职业——是我正在谈论的。我认为更重要的是，你完全可以在不知道自己想做什么的情况下感到满足。
And even if you haven't discovered your dream job, or maybe you don't think that you have one, it doesn't mean that you're not going to be happy. It doesn't mean that you're not going to be confident. And it doesn't mean that you need to have a dream job. So what I want to talk about next is the alternatives to the dream job philosophy. And how we can almost re-center our relationship towards figuring it out. How we can re-center our relationship towards work without putting that undue pressure in ourselves and falling into that dangerous cycle of feeling really guilty and really shameful and feeling anxious about what we want to do.
And even if you haven't discovered your dream job, or maybe you don't think that you have one, it doesn't mean that you're not going to be happy. It doesn't mean that you're not going to be confident. And it doesn't mean that you need to have a dream job. So what I want to talk about next is the alternatives to the dream job philosophy. And how we can almost re-center our relationship towards figuring it out. How we can re-center our relationship towards work without putting that undue pressure in ourselves and falling into that dangerous cycle of feeling really guilty and really shameful and feeling anxious about what we want to do.|||即使你还没有发现你的梦想工作，或者你可能认为自己根本没有梦想工作，这并不意味着你不会快乐。这并不意味着你不会自信。这也不意味着你非得拥有一个梦想工作。所以我接下来要谈的是“梦想工作”哲学的替代方案。以及我们如何能够重新确立我们与弄清楚这一切的关系。我们如何能够重新调整我们对工作的态度，而不在自己身上施加过度的压力，并陷入那种感到非常内疚、非常羞耻、对我们想做的事情感到焦虑的危险循环中。
Our next partner has a product I use literally every day. I started taking AG1 because I've been on a bit of a health journey. I wanted to take better care of my immune system and my gut health. And with one delicious scoop of AG1, you're essentially absorbing 75 high-quality vitamins, minerals, probiotics, all that good stuff. And it's really great for your nervous system and your immune system. It's just one simple micro-habit that you can incorporate into your daily life with big benefits. It's super lifestyle friendly.
Our next partner has a product I use literally every day. I started taking AG1 because I've been on a bit of a health journey. I wanted to take better care of my immune system and my gut health. And with one delicious scoop of AG1, you're essentially absorbing 75 high-quality vitamins, minerals, probiotics, all that good stuff. And it's really great for your nervous system and your immune system. It's just one simple micro-habit that you can incorporate into your daily life with big benefits. It's super lifestyle friendly.|||我们的下一个合作伙伴有一款我几乎每天都在使用的产品。我开始服用 AG1，因为我最近一直在进行一段健康之旅。我想要更好地照顾我的免疫系统和肠道健康。只需美味的一勺 AG1，你基本上就能吸收 75 种高质量的维生素、矿物质、益生菌以及所有这些好东西。它对你的神经系统和免疫系统真的非常好。这只是一个简单的小习惯，你可以把它融入日常生活，并获得巨大的好处。它对各种生活方式都非常友好。
And Athletic Greens is also a climate-neutral certified company, which we absolutely love on the show. Right now, it is time to reclaim your health and arm your immune system with a convenient daily nutrition. It's just one scoop in a cup of water every day. That's it. No need for a million different pills and supplements to look after your health. And to make it easy, Athletic Greens is going to give you a free one-year supply of immune-supporting vitamin D and five free travel packs with your first purchase. All you have to do is visit athletic greens.com slash Gemma.
And Athletic Greens is also a climate-neutral certified company, which we absolutely love on the show. Right now, it is time to reclaim your health and arm your immune system with a convenient daily nutrition. It's just one scoop in a cup of water every day. That's it. No need for a million different pills and supplements to look after your health. And to make it easy, Athletic Greens is going to give you a free one-year supply of immune-supporting vitamin D and five free travel packs with your first purchase. All you have to do is visit athletic greens.com slash Gemma.|||而且 Athletic Greens 还是一家获得气候中和认证的公司，这也是我们在节目中非常喜爱的。现在，是时候重获健康，用便捷的每日营养武装你的免疫系统了。每天只需在一杯水中加入一勺。就是这样。不需要数百万种不同的药丸和补充剂来照顾你的健康。为了方便起见，在您首次购买时，Athletic Greens 将为您提供免费的一年期支持免疫力的维生素 D 供应以及五份免费旅行装。您只需访问 athletic greens.com 斜杠 Gemma。
again that's athletic greens.com slash gemma to take ownership over your health and pick up the ultimate daily nutritional insurance like i said there's no denying that enjoying your job is important you know statistics do show that people who are more engaged in the work they enjoy um they're they're happier they are happier but it doesn't mean that there's only one job that's going to make you happy and then if you're not doing that you're destined for misery and this cognitive scientist from the University of Bristol he wrote a really fascinating article on this and i really wanted to share it because what he concluded is that loving what you do doesn't actually lead to greater happiness despite the temptation to equate happiness with being successful at work or loving what you do often there is this pattern where you start working harder
again that's athletic greens.com slash gemma to take ownership over your health and pick up the ultimate daily nutritional insurance like i said there's no denying that enjoying your job is important you know statistics do show that people who are more engaged in the work they enjoy um they're they're happier they are happier but it doesn't mean that there's only one job that's going to make you happy and then if you're not doing that you're destined for misery and this cognitive scientist from the University of Bristol he wrote a really fascinating article on this and i really wanted to share it because what he concluded is that loving what you do doesn't actually lead to greater happiness despite the temptation to equate happiness with being successful at work or loving what you do often there is this pattern where you start working harder|||再次强调，那是 athletic greens.com 斜杠 gemma，来掌控你的健康，并挑选终极的每日营养保险。就像我说的，不可否认享受工作很重要，你知道统计数据确实表明那些更多地参与他们喜欢的工作的人，嗯，他们更快乐，他们确实更快乐，但这并不意味着只有一份工作能让你快乐，如果你没做那个工作，你就注定了悲惨。这位来自布里斯托尔大学的认知科学家就此写了一篇非常迷人的文章，我真的很想分享它，因为他的结论是：热爱你所做的事实际上并不会带来更大的幸福感，尽管人们很容易把幸福等同于在工作中获得成功或热爱你所做的事，但通常会存在这样一种模式：你开始更加努力地工作……
and harder to the point where all of a sudden you feel guilty if you're not not working. And the moment that happens, your work-life balance and your family obligations and your hobbies and your life beyond your career, it begins to suffer. Sometimes you arrive at what you think is your dream destination, your dream job, and you realize that it's not at all what you expected. And not only that, that, you know, there are sometimes factors that make it really unenjoyable or really unpleasant, you know, the long hours. The rewards are lower. It's more physically demanding than you thought it would be. And I think in that moment, whether or not that position is your dream job, it's not going to matter if you're unhappy. And you should feel confident enough to be able to change.
and harder to the point where all of a sudden you feel guilty if you're not not working. And the moment that happens, your work-life balance and your family obligations and your hobbies and your life beyond your career, it begins to suffer. Sometimes you arrive at what you think is your dream destination, your dream job, and you realize that it's not at all what you expected. And not only that, that, you know, there are sometimes factors that make it really unenjoyable or really unpleasant, you know, the long hours. The rewards are lower. It's more physically demanding than you thought it would be. And I think in that moment, whether or not that position is your dream job, it's not going to matter if you're unhappy. And you should feel confident enough to be able to change.|||以至于突然之间，如果你不工作，你就会感到内疚。一旦这种情况发生，你的工作与生活平衡、家庭义务、爱好以及职业之外的生活，就会开始受到影响。有时你到达了你认为是梦想目的地的梦想工作，却意识到它根本不是你所期望的那样。不仅如此，你知道，有时有一些因素会让它变得真的很没有乐趣或很不愉快，你知道，漫长的工作时间。回报更低。它比你想象的要消耗更多体力。我认为在那一刻，无论那个职位是否是你的梦想工作，如果你不快乐，这就都不重要了。而且你应该有足够的自信去做出改变。
And you should feel supported enough to be able to choose something different. It's not always about the specific job you're working. It's about things like the environment in which you're performing that role. It's about the people that you're associated with. You know, there are times that I was happier working as a barrister or as a waiter. than I am in my professional job, even though one of those, you know, from society's perspective, comes with more prestige because it's not always about your job title, it's about the environment in which it's being performed. And I do firmly believe that there's not one perfect job or career out there for all of us. And not only that, there's not one job that's going to suit our lives. I think humans are incredibly malleable, they're adaptable, they're flexible creatures with a lot of
And you should feel supported enough to be able to choose something different. It's not always about the specific job you're working. It's about things like the environment in which you're performing that role. It's about the people that you're associated with. You know, there are times that I was happier working as a barrister or as a waiter. than I am in my professional job, even though one of those, you know, from society's perspective, comes with more prestige because it's not always about your job title, it's about the environment in which it's being performed. And I do firmly believe that there's not one perfect job or career out there for all of us. And not only that, there's not one job that's going to suit our lives. I think humans are incredibly malleable, they're adaptable, they're flexible creatures with a lot of|||并且你应该获得足够的支持去选择不同的事情。这并不总是关乎你具体在做什么工作。这关乎诸如你扮演那个角色的环境之类的事情。这关乎与你交往的人。你知道，有时我作为大律师或服务员工作时，比我现在从事专业工作时更快乐，尽管其中一个工作，你知道的，从社会的角度来看，伴随着更高的威望，因为这并不总是关乎你的头衔，而是关乎开展工作的环境。我坚信，对于我们所有人来说，并没有哪一个完美的工作或职业。不仅如此，也没有哪一份工作能完全适合我们的生活。我认为人类是极其具有可塑性、适应性、灵活性的生物，拥有很多……
facets and a lot of strengths and many of our strengths and qualities are going to change over time. And many of our desires for what we want from our lives are going to change over time as well. And I read the statistic that the average person born in this century is going to have three to four career changes in their lives. That's us. That's this generation. You know, I've already had two career changes. And probably like you, I'm only in my first decade.
facets and a lot of strengths and many of our strengths and qualities are going to change over time. And many of our desires for what we want from our lives are going to change over time as well. And I read the statistic that the average person born in this century is going to have three to four career changes in their lives. That's us. That's this generation. You know, I've already had two career changes. And probably like you, I'm only in my first decade.|||侧面和许多优势，随着时间的推移，我们的许多优势和品质都会发生变化。我们对生活中想要的东西的许多愿望也会随着时间而改变。我读到过这样一组统计数据：这个世纪出生的人一生中平均会有三到四次职业转变。那就是我们。这就是这一代人。你知道，我已经经历过两次职业转变了。可能和你一样，我才刚刚步入成年后的头十年。
of adulthood. And the dream job that I thought I wanted and my final destination at the time, it certainly was not my dream job. And I'm doing something entirely different now. And one thing I realized when I was thinking about my own journey is that there isn't one thing that was going to make me happy. Not one job, not one career. Those jobs made me happy for a time. But there are other things out there that I don't even know about yet that are probably going to fulfill me even more. Think about it this way. We don't just have one hobby that makes us happy. We don't just decide, you know, I love painting and that's all I'm going to do because it makes me happy and I'm good at it. We don't just have one friend that we like being around or one really amazing skill or one
of adulthood. And the dream job that I thought I wanted and my final destination at the time, it certainly was not my dream job. And I'm doing something entirely different now. And one thing I realized when I was thinking about my own journey is that there isn't one thing that was going to make me happy. Not one job, not one career. Those jobs made me happy for a time. But there are other things out there that I don't even know about yet that are probably going to fulfill me even more. Think about it this way. We don't just have one hobby that makes us happy. We don't just decide, you know, I love painting and that's all I'm going to do because it makes me happy and I'm good at it. We don't just have one friend that we like being around or one really amazing skill or one|||而我曾经以为自己想要的梦想工作以及当时的最终目的地，绝对不是我的梦想工作。我现在做的是完全不同的事情。在思考我自己的心路历程时，我意识到的一件事是，并没有哪一件事能让我快乐。不是某一份工作，也不是某一个职业。那些工作曾一度让我快乐。但在外面还有其他我甚至还不知道的事情，可能会让我感到更加充实。换个角度想。我们不只有一个能让我们快乐的爱好。我们不会只是决定，你知道的，我热爱画画，这就是我唯一要做的事，因为它让我快乐，而且我擅长它。我们不只有一个喜欢与之相处的朋友，或者一项真正了不起的技能，或者一个……
favorite food or one favorite place. There are many things that make us fulfilled and happy. And the same goes for the line of work we choose. So I'm hoping. that if you feel stuck, that makes you feel better. That whatever you're doing right now, whatever you think you want to do right now, there are things that you haven't even discovered yet, which could fill an even deeper, you know, an even deeper need or desire within you. And so I wanted to kind of talk about and talk to the people who might be experiencing that right now. And some of the tips for overcoming the anxiety about finding the right career path for you or the right job.
favorite food or one favorite place. There are many things that make us fulfilled and happy. And the same goes for the line of work we choose. So I'm hoping. that if you feel stuck, that makes you feel better. That whatever you're doing right now, whatever you think you want to do right now, there are things that you haven't even discovered yet, which could fill an even deeper, you know, an even deeper need or desire within you. And so I wanted to kind of talk about and talk to the people who might be experiencing that right now. And some of the tips for overcoming the anxiety about finding the right career path for you or the right job.|||最喜欢的食物或一个最喜欢的地方。有很多事情能让我们感到充实和快乐。我们选择的职业也是如此。所以我希望，如果你感到迷茫，这能让你感觉好受一些。无论你现在在做什么，无论你认为自己现在想做什么，都有些事情是你甚至还没有发现的，它们可以满足你内心更深处的、你知道的、更深层的需求或欲望。所以我想要谈谈并与那些现在可能正在经历这种状况的人聊聊。以及一些克服寻找适合你的职业道路或合适工作的焦虑的建议。
Like I said, there is an entire. higher field of psychology dedicated to this and dedicated to this idea of our professional lives and there's so much literature on how we can find jobs we find fulfilling and we can create meaning even than those that we never dreamed of. Firstly, instead of trying to imagine a specific career you think you'd be good at or that would make you happy, take a more holistic perspective. I want you to ask yourself, you know, the following questions. What do you love doing? What is your greatest personal strength? What is an activity you could spend hours on? What is a subject at school that you never really had to work that hard at, but you still did really well? What are some of your non-negotiables
Like I said, there is an entire. higher field of psychology dedicated to this and dedicated to this idea of our professional lives and there's so much literature on how we can find jobs we find fulfilling and we can create meaning even than those that we never dreamed of. Firstly, instead of trying to imagine a specific career you think you'd be good at or that would make you happy, take a more holistic perspective. I want you to ask yourself, you know, the following questions. What do you love doing? What is your greatest personal strength? What is an activity you could spend hours on? What is a subject at school that you never really had to work that hard at, but you still did really well? What are some of your non-negotiables|||就像我说的，有一个完整的……更高级别的心理学领域专门研究这个问题，专门研究我们职业生活的这个概念，并且有大量的文献关于我们如何能找到让我们觉得充实的工作，甚至可以创造出那些我们从未梦想过的意义。首先，与其去想象一个你认为自己会擅长或会让你快乐的具体职业，不如采取更全面的视角。我希望你问自己，你知道的，以下这些问题。你喜欢做什么？你最大的个人优势是什么？有什么活动你可以花上好几个小时去做？在学校里有什么科目你其实不用花太多力气，但依然学得很好？有哪些是你的底线或不容妥协的因素……
for your personal life? What kind of life do you want to have beyond work? I think this reveals a lot more than simply choosing your job at a certain age and deciding that that's the one. That's what I've decided to do. Let me use an example here. You know, maybe one of your greatest strengths is that you really connect with people. You're really nurturing and at school you did really well in biology and anatomy. But you have a desire to balance your work life with travel and maybe you want a family. So you want to work part time or take periods of time off.
for your personal life? What kind of life do you want to have beyond work? I think this reveals a lot more than simply choosing your job at a certain age and deciding that that's the one. That's what I've decided to do. Let me use an example here. You know, maybe one of your greatest strengths is that you really connect with people. You're really nurturing and at school you did really well in biology and anatomy. But you have a desire to balance your work life with travel and maybe you want a family. So you want to work part time or take periods of time off.|||对于你的个人生活？除了工作之外，你想过什么样的生活？我认为这比单纯地在某个年龄选择一份工作并决定那就是你的目标要揭示出多得多的东西。这就是我决定要做的事。让我在这里举个例子。你知道，也许你最大的优势之一就是你真的很擅长与人建立联系。你真的很有抚育心，在学校里你生物和解剖学学得非常好。但你有一种愿望，想要平衡工作生活与旅行，也许你还想要一个家庭。所以你想做兼职或者定期休假一段时间。
if you just took one of those elements at face value, you know, people told you that you were really good at science and you were really studious, you might be like, okay, well, then I should be a doctor, and that's going to make me really happy and fulfilled. But there are other elements of that self-appraisal that we're forgetting, which is the flexibility and the connection to people. You know, if you're a surgeon, most of the time,
if you just took one of those elements at face value, you know, people told you that you were really good at science and you were really studious, you might be like, okay, well, then I should be a doctor, and that's going to make me really happy and fulfilled. But there other elements of that self-appraisal that we're forgetting, which is the flexibility and the connection to people. You know, if you're a surgeon, most of the time,|||如果你只是从表面上看待这些要素中的某一个，你知道，人们告诉你你很擅长科学而且你很好学，你可能会想，好吧，那我就应该成为一名医生，这会让我感到非常快乐和充实。但自我评估中还有其他一些我们正在遗忘的要素，那就是灵活性以及与人们的联系。你知道，如果你是一名外科医生，大多数时候，
your patient's probably going to be anisicized, so you're not really going to be able to connect with someone who's unconscious. And maybe you would actually be happier as a travelling nurse or as a school nurse, something that allows you to satisfy the other things that are important to you while still leveraging your skills and your strengths. And it's probably going to make you a lot happier when we assess the full picture and the scope of our life. It may be a better decision because our expectations are more aligned.
your patient's probably going to be anisicized, so you're not really going to be able to connect with someone who's unconscious. And maybe you would actually be happier as a travelling nurse or as a school nurse, something that allows you to satisfy the other things that are important to you while still leveraging your skills and your strengths. And it's probably going to make you a lot happier when we assess the full picture and the scope of our life. It may be a better decision because our expectations are more aligned.|||你的病人可能处于麻醉状态，所以你实际上无法与一个失去意识的人建立连接。也许你作为一名旅行护士或学校护士会更快乐，这样既能满足对你很重要的其他事情，同时还能发挥你的技能和优势。当我们评估全局和生活范围时，这可能会让你开心得多。这可能是一个更好的决定，因为我们的期望更加契合。
I guess what I'm trying to say is that when we only see ourselves doing one thing, we limit ourselves. So instead, focus on, you know, those fundamentals of why you want to choose a particular career and give yourself the freedom to see where else you may fit. What might suit you better? What might actually make you happier, even if it's not as prestigious, even if it's, you know, doesn't require as much study. Instead of finding a career that you love, find something that you love. find something that's going to fulfill you, regardless of how much you're getting paid, regardless of your co-workers, regardless of where you live, find something that's going to suit your life and your strengths. And I think another tip is to allow yourself to be uncomfortable
I guess what I'm trying to say is that when we only see ourselves doing one thing, we limit ourselves. So instead, focus on, you know, those fundamentals of why you want to choose a particular career and give yourself the freedom to see where else you may fit. What might suit you better? What might actually make you happier, even if it's not as prestigious, even if it's, you know, doesn't require as much study. Instead of finding a career that you love, find something that you love. find something that's going to fulfill you, regardless of how much you're getting paid, regardless of your co-workers, regardless of where you live, find something that's going to suit your life and your strengths. And I think another tip is to allow yourself to be uncomfortable|||我想表达的是，当我们只看到自己做一件事时，我们限制了自己。所以相反，专注于，你知道，你为什么想选择某个特定职业的基本原则，并给自己自由去看看你还能适合什么地方。什么可能更适合你？什么实际上能让你更快乐，即使它没有那么声望卓著，即使它，你知道，不需要那么多的学习。与其寻找你热爱的职业，不如寻找你热爱的事物。寻找能让你感到充实的事物，无论你的薪水多少，无论你的同事是谁，无论你住在哪里，寻找适合你的生活和优势的事物。我认为另一个建议是允许自己对……感到不自在
with uncertainty. Not much in life is certain, but the one thing that is is change and inconsistency. It's a really good reminder, not just when we think about our careers, when we think, think about everything. There are jobs in the future that haven't even been created yet, life-changing moments that will completely alter your entire outlook and expectations for your life. There will be so many opportunities that you cannot imagine and thinking that you need to commit to one dream job, especially at this age, especially when we're 20 and we're allowed to make mistakes and try things out, I think it actually restricts those opportunities. Your dreams are going to change. It's normal to not be the same person with the same goals
with uncertainty. Not much in life is certain, but the one thing that is is change and inconsistency. It's a really good reminder, not just when we think about our careers, when we think, think about everything. There are jobs in the future that haven't even been created yet, life-changing moments that will completely alter your entire outlook and expectations for your life. There will be so many opportunities that you cannot imagine and thinking that you need to commit to one dream job, especially at this age, especially when we're 20 and we're allowed to make mistakes and try things out, I think it actually restricts those opportunities. Your dreams are going to change. It's normal to not be the same person with the same goals|||不确定性。生活中没有多少事情是确定的，但唯一确定的就是变化和不一致。这是一个非常好的提醒，不仅在我们思考职业时，当我们思考、思考一切时。未来会有甚至尚未被创造出来的工作，会有改变人生的时刻，将彻底改变你对人生的整个看法和期望。会有无数你无法想象的机会，而认为自己需要全身心投入到一个梦想工作中，特别是在这个年龄，特别是当我们二十岁、被允许犯错和尝试的时候，我认为这实际上限制了这些机会。你的梦想会改变。拥有不同的目标、不再是同一个人，这很正常。
as you were when you were 18 and five years from now you could be living a completely different life based on circumstances both within and beyond your control and being comfortable with the knowledge that things will change and that uncertainty will allow you to embrace more options and opportunities and maybe end up at a place that is better for you than if you did believe this myth of the dream job and you did pursue it to, you know, the very ends of the earth. One final reminder that I know we've already mentioned, but I really want to finish on this note is to remind you that if you're feeling stuck, if you haven't figured out your dream job yet, regardless of whether you think it's real or not, what you choose to do for a living is
就像你18岁时那样，从现在起的五年里，你可能会过上完全不同的生活，这取决于你能力范围之内和之外的各种情况。欣然接受事物会发生变化这一事实，这种不确定性将让你能够拥抱更多的选择和机会，也许最终会到达一个比你盲目追求所谓“梦想工作”并为此赴汤蹈火更好的地方。最后再提醒大家一次，我知道我们已经提过，但我真的很想以此作为结束：如果你感到迷茫，如果你还没找到你的梦想工作，无论你觉得它是真是假，你选择以什么为生
not the sole source of your identity. We get so wrapped up in wanting to appear like we have it all together and doing something that is admirable that we forget that life is a lot more than how we choose to pay our bills. Our jobs can just give us the means to an end to enjoy the other things in life because our entire lives and not our careers. You can build up so many other components of your life that are going to make you equally happy. And I think it's a myth that it is the sole responsibility of our jobs to do that, to make us happy. Your life does and will continue to consist of so many more components than just what you choose to do for work. And I think pursuing a dream job, especially something that's really difficult, it might bring us satisfaction, but sometimes
并不是你身份的唯一来源。我们总是太纠结于让自己看起来一切都游刃有余、做着令人羡慕的事，以至于忘记了生活远比我们如何付账单要丰富得多。我们的工作可以只是维持生活的手段，让我们去享受生活中的其他事物，因为我们的全部生命并不等于职业。你可以建立生活中许多其他同样能让你快乐的部分。我认为“工作是我们快乐的唯一责任”这种想法是一个神话。你的生活过去、现在并将继续包含比你选择的工作更多的组成部分。我认为追求梦想工作，尤其是那些非常困难的工作，可能会给我们带来满足感，但有时
if we do that with too much of a singular narrow focus, we end up in a place where we realize that we've neglected other things. And I think we can be happy in any job that we've choose. As long as it allows you to live your life, as long as you're focused on the things beyond your career that make you happy, as long as it pays your bills, you're still going to feel satisfied. You're still going to feel fulfilled. And we should allow ourselves, I think, to kind of relegate that idea that there's only one thing that we're born to do, to understand that the world is large, the world is wide, and there are opportunities that we don't even know about yet that are going to completely change the course of your life, the course of history.
如果我们过于单一狭隘地专注于此，最终会发现自己忽略了其他重要的事情。我认为，无论选择什么工作，只要它能维持生计，只要你专注于职业之外能让你快乐的事物，只要它能付清账单，我们就能在任何工作中感到快乐，依然会感到满足和充实。我认为我们应该抛弃那种“人这辈子生来就只有一件事可做”的想法，去明白世界很大，世界很宽广，还有许多我们甚至还不知道的机会，它们将彻底改变你的人生轨迹和历史进程。
I think that's a lovely message to end on. This episode was, like I said, I cannot believe I didn't do it sooner because I get so many emails and messages all the time of people being like, I really don't know what I'm doing. I really have no idea. And I'm going to tell you, I don't either. I have no idea. And there are so many people in their 20s in my life who have no idea as well. And that is totally okay.
我认为这是一个很好的收尾。正如我所说，这一集我真不敢相信我没有早点做，因为我一直收到太多电子邮件和私信，大家都在说：“我真的不知道自己在做什么，我真的毫无头绪。”我要告诉你的是，我也不知道，我毫无头绪。我生活中的许多二十多几岁的人也同样毫无头绪，这完全没问题。
It's totally okay. Like I said, you're going to have so many career changes. There's going to be so many things that happen, newfound hobbies, newfound passions. And nurturing the other things in your life that aren't just based in work will allow you to have a healthier relationship to your career and a healthier relationship to your professional life. So thank you so much for listening. I really hope you enjoyed it. I hope that if you're feeling a bit of career anxiety or feeling a bit stuck right now,
这完全没问题。就像我说的，你会有很多次职业转变，会有很多事情发生，比如新的爱好、新的热情。培养生活中除了工作之外的其他事物，能让你与职业保持更健康的联系，与你的职业生涯建立更健康的关系。非常感谢大家的收听，我真心希望你们喜欢这一集。我希望如果你现在正经历一些职业焦虑或感到有些迷茫，
it made you feel better. I really hope that that is the case. And if you enjoy this episode, feel free. If you feel cool to do so to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. And if you want more content like this, follow at that psychology podcast on Instagram. Every month I let my listeners decide what episodes they want to hear.
它能让你感觉好一些。我真心希望如此。如果你喜欢这一集，随时欢迎在苹果播客、Spotify或你现在收听节目的任何地方留下五星好评。如果你想要更多这样的内容，请在Instagram上关注@thatpsychologypodcast。每个月我都会让听众决定他们想听什么样的主题。
They get to decide what comes next, what's on the show, And it's also where I announce the guests that are coming on, people that are coming on merchandise that it's coming out soon, so many different things. So follow me over there if you want. And I hope you have an amazing day. Thank you for listening. Thank you for coming on this journey with me. And I will see you next week for another episode.
他们可以决定接下来播什么、节目里有什么，这也是我宣布嘉宾、即将登场的嘉宾以及即将推出的周边商品等各种消息的地方。如果你想了解，就去那边关注我吧。祝你有美好的一天。谢谢收听，谢谢你和我一起踏上这段旅程，我们下周同一时间见。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's. experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit are armored? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people
嘿，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个节目探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在别处根本无法安全展开的坦诚对话，而你是与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士在交流。有多少男人把西装当成铠甲？它向世界释放出一种“别来惹我”的信号。但仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2%，这就是那个比例：
who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. They take matters into their own hands. I bowed. I will be his last target.
在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神韧性、体能训练以及在我们这个奇特现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你将脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me.
当一群女性发现她们约会过的竟是同一个声名狼藉的骗子时，她们决定亲自动手。我起誓，我将成为他最后的猎物。
84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex E. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year.
他绝不会就这样逃脱惩罚。他会得到应有的下场。我们总说要相信好闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
84年对我意义重大。我是Sam J.，我是Alex E.每期节目中，我们挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧同仁以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。那真是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有比这对于黑人来说更重要的一年了。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。这是一个iHeart播客。人类出品，必属精品。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。